Mike how are you oh great Dan are you
buddy I'm great
we have any drama leading up to the
draft oh well you know the Cleveland
Browns are keeping their cards pressed
close to the vest they want us to think
they may take miles Garrett they may
take Mitchell true Biscay I think the
NFL likes it that way remember last year
the Rams they they stretched it all the
way out to the last minute even though
everybody knew they were taking Jared
Goff it's the ultimate reality show and
you need to have some drama to make it
interesting does the NFL tell these
teams at the top of the draft
stretch it out we want drama attached to
this oh I don't know that they expressly
tell them I think it's implied and I
think also you know it's part of that
opportunity that for one day for 10
minutes if nothing else the Cleveland
Browns will be the focal point of the
National Football League for a team that
won a single game last year that's a
pretty good deal to have all eyes on
Cleveland for that 10 minutes so you
just stretch it out you milk and I also
think at a certain level too they want
to keep the phone line open given the
possibility someone calls up and offers
them something for that first overall
pick and when you have two names
attached to your potential plan at
number one Miles Garrett Mitchell true
Biscay if you go down a few spots and
you get true Biscay and you let someone
else take garrett you can leak this idea
that hey true bisque 'is the guy we
would have taken anyway so we come out
of this ahead we still get the guy and
we get more stuff to help make the team
better what do you think is the national
headline tomorrow with the draft
something that we don't expect right
isn't that what it always is or at least
we should we saw that last year with the
gas mask long video I think the big
thing is going to be the number of
quarterbacks though because you've got
quarterbacks
that are close to retirement and you've
got teams that are looking to replace
them with potential franchise
quarterbacks and then you have the teams
that just have crappy quarterbacks or no
quarterbacks and they're going to be
looking for quarterbacks as well and I
know we started this process with teams
speaking very poorly about this class
and it's not very good and this that the
other thing as we get closer and closer
they got the over/under in Vegas at
three and a half and I think it's going
to go for and there's an outside chance
it goes five the
because where else are you going to find
potential franchise quarterbacks they're
not available typically in free agency
and if they are there's usually a reason
for it like a serious injury so you got
to hope you can find a guy that you can
groom and you have the luxury if you've
got Drew Brees Philip Rivers Ben
Roethlisberger Eli Manning as the
starter for the next year or two
putting that guy on the bench and
letting him learn and it worked out
pretty well for Aaron Rodgers three
years on the bench in Green Bay behind
Brett Farr but you also want them in the
first round as well because you get to
lock them up a year longer than if they
go after that yeah that fifth year
option is a huge bonus but you know the
other thing to that anchor of being a
first-round pick that pressure the
expectation that's why it's almost
better for teams at the bottom that had
quarterbacks to say I'm not going to be
compelled to put the guy on the field I
do get him for five years he learns from
a veteran now some of these veterans may
not be thrilled
Carson Palmer more than willing to
mentor a young quarterback but what's
Ben Roethlisberger going to say we
already know what Drew Brees is going to
say he said it why you going to use a
first-round pick on a quarterback when
I'm still here and I think we're going
to have another layer of drama that
emerges if some of these teams that that
know the clock is ticking very loudly on
their current quarterback decides to use
a first-round pick on another one he's
Mike Florio from pro football TOCOM if
you were going to look at the
quarterback most likely to be a bust
you know I've interviewed each of the
top six and I like all of them now I
can't comment on how their game is going
to translate from the college level the
pro level we know there's a ceiling at
some point between what they've done in
college and what they're under whether
they get to the end of the Pro Football
Hall of Fame there's a ceiling there and
it's a crapshoot at the 50/50
proposition you know I look at Mitchell
true Biscay and I say this guy's got 13
games of starting experience at the
college level and he's regarded
potentially as the first overall pick
and that puts only more pressure on him
and you go to a place like Cleveland
where if they stink again this year are
the Haslam's going to continue with the
current front office and coaching staff
and true Biscay could get thrown into a
vortex where even if he otherwise in
another system with another coach with
another owner another city would be
great
you may have no chance in Cleveland so
that's the one thing we have to factor
into this these guys are going to get
assigned to teams that they wouldn't
have maybe chosen if they had their
druthers and you could have a guy who
would have been great somewhere else who
goes to Cleveland er goes to another
city and it all falls apart and it's
really not his fault yeah I'd rather go
to the Arizona Cardinals than I would be
Cleveland Brown I'd rather go late in
the first then early in the first if it
meant the difference of going to
Cleveland or going to Arizona I did look
at the top two picks Cleveland at one
San Francisco at - you've got Kyle
Shanahan and John Lynch with six year
contracts with no offset meaning they're
getting paid the full amount of their
salary for the next six years whether
they're there or not whether they're
working for someone else or not the
49ers are going to keep these guys
around so between those two teams it
makes more sense to go to San Francisco
because you know that Shanahan and Lynch
are going to be there for more than a
year or two I think in Cleveland based
on what we've seen the last five years
there's no guarantee anybody's going to
be back next year what advice would you
have for Ohio State defensive back Arian
Conley well I mean the hardest thing to
do the easiest vice to give is the
hardest thing to have happen at this
point
get yourself cleared by tonight that's
not going to happen and and without full
clearance he's not going to go in the
first round now this is unlike the Lyle
Collins situation Dan because there is
evidence out there the team's know the
name of the alleged victim the team's
know who the witnesses are the teams
have been able to do research and come
to some sort of an educated conclusion
not a final answer as to what happened
but number one people don't know what
happened in the hotel room number two
people don't know what's going to happen
going forward but if you can get enough
information and these teams all have
retired law enforcement personnel who
know who to call who to talk to how to
get to the bottom of things you make an
educated guess and you know I think that
someone is going to take them in round
three I think at this point it's
impossible for Gary and Conley to get
himself back into round one and really
the only way to make that happen is to
find a way to convince the alleged
victim to either recant or say I'm not
going to push this it's not going to
happen nothing is going to happen going
forward and even then I think if there's
not enough time for teams to process it
and come to the kind of conclusion
necessary to put his name on the card in
round one who hears his name sooner
garyun connelly or jill Mixon yeah you
know that's a great question and I am
saying that to buy time yeah I really
don't know at this point I mean I I've
heard all sorts of different things
about mixin and there are some people
who put them at the bottom around one in
mock drafts and some people say round
two right now I'd lean a little bit more
strongly with mixin because with Nixon
we know everything we need to know it's
over it's finite it's closed with
Connally it's still at the very
beginning it can go a lot of different
ways and you may have some owners who
are skittish about giving the green
light you know we've talked a lot about
how Nixon is going to be an owners pick
Conley definitely is going to be an
owners pick if you're a GM or a coach
and you're thinking about taking Conley
you better be darn sure your owner is
okay with it and understand that this
thing could go very very badly from the
standpoint of the distraction of a
prosecution and maybe at some point you
have to renounce your rights to the guy
you have nothing to show for a
third-round draft pick if that's the
round he goes in so I think that that
causes me to go with Nixon as likely to
be taken higher than Conley at this
point have fun tonight Mike thanks for
joining us all right Dan say bye that's
Mike Florio pro football talk comm the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience